འདི།
ཁོ་རང་ང་རང་ལ་ཞེད་གི་རེད་བས། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་ཕལ་བསྡད་གི་ཡིན་ཞེད་གི་ཡོད་་ན།
གདོན་འདྲེ་ཡིན་ན་ཞེད་གི་རེད་བས་ཁོ།
འདི་མི། ཞི་མི་བྱེད་ག ཞི་མི།
ཞི་མི། ཡ་ཁོ་རང་ཨ་མ་དེ་པུ་གུ་སྒང་ལ་མ་༼འཛར་༽ན།
བལྟ་ཨ། འདི་འདྲས་འདྲ་བོ་འདུག་ག འདི།
ཁྱེད་རང་གོན་༼ཞག༽
སྐད་མེད་པ་བྱས་༼ཞག༽
འདི། ད་མཐོང་སོང་ང་། འདི་མཐོང་སོང་ང་། ད་འདིའི་བཞག།
ང་མཐོང་མ་སོང་ད། ཁྱེད་རང་སུ་ཡིན་པས།
མ་རེད་འདུག་ག མིག་ཤེལ་གོན་ཉན་དེ། སྐེ་ག་འདྲ་ཡོད།
སྐེ་ནག་པོ་ཏིག་ཙ་འདུག
འདི་མོ་ཊ་ཆུང་ཆུང་གཅིག་འདུག་ད་ད་གིན་ནས།
ཨ་ར།
སྤྲད་ད། སྤྲད་ད།
ང་༼འཛར་༽༼ཡ་༽མིན་(ད)། ༼ཨི་འདྲས་༽བྱེད་༼ཡ་༽ཡིན།
སྤྲད་ད། ང་ལ་སྤྲད་གི་མི་འདུག
མ་བསླད་ད།
ཨ་ཚ་་་་
སུ་༼ལྷེབ་ཚ་༽ཞིག་་བཀོག་སོང་།
པེ་ཤག་སྤྲད་མ་སོང་ང་ད་གིན།
པེ་ཤག་ལབ་ན་དངུལ།
དངུལ་ཕ་གིར་འདུག་ག
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ངས་སྤྲད་ཡ་མིན། ཁྱེད་རང་ང་འདི་ནང་ལ་བཞག་ཚར་ཡིན། ང་སྤྲད་ཡ་མིན་(ལོ)། ང་ལ་མང་པོ་ཡོད་(ལོ)།
ང་ལ་དངུལ་མང་པོ་ཡོད། སང་ཉིན་ར་ང་ལ་སྨན་མང་པོ་ཡོའོ་ཡོད།
དངུལ།
དངུལ་པེ་ཤག་ཉོ་ཡ་ཡིན། ང་རྔན་པ་ཉོ་ཡ་ཡིན།
འོན་ཧོ། མ་རེད། མ་རེད་རྔན་པ་ཉོ་ཡ་ཡིན་ལབ་ཡིན། རྔན་པ་ང་རང་ང་རང་ཟ་ཡ་ཡིན།
སུ་ལ་སྤྲད་
འདི་འདི་ལ་བཞག
ངུས་སོང་།
ཡོད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽བཞག་ཤོག
མེད། མེད། ཡོད། ཡོད།
ང་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་ཡིན་ད།
དགོས་བས། སྐྲ་རིང་པོ་དགོས་བས།
སྐྲ་རིང་པོ་དགོས་བས་ལབ་ཡིན། ང་སྐྲ་རིང་པོ་ལ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད། ང་ལ་ག་རེ་བྱས་ནས་མ་ལབ་ད།
ཁྱེད་རང་སྐྲ་ཆུང་ཆུང་ལ་དགའ་བོ་ཡོད་བས།
སྐྲ་ཐུང་ཐུང་དགའ་བོ་ཡོད་བས།
སྐྲ་ཆུང་ཆུང་། ཤོག
ཨ་མ། ཤི་མ་ཤི།
ཨ་ཕ་འདི། ཧཧཧ འདི་འདྲས་མ་བྱེད་ཨ། མ་བྱེད་ཨ།
ཁ་ལག་མེད་ང་ལ།
ཁ་ལག་མེད། ཁྱེད་རང་ནང་ལ་ཁ་ལག་ཡོད་བས། ང་ལ་ཁ་ལག་མེད་༼ཨ་ནས༽།
སྐྱུག་པ་མང་པོ།
མནན་ད།
འདི་བསྟན་ད། བསྟན་ད།
སྒྲུང་སྙན་པོ་གཅིག་དང་པོ། མ་རེད་དང་པོ།
མཐའ་མ་བཤད་ད།
ད་ཡིན་ད། ཡིན་ད། ད་ཡིན་ད། སྔན་མ།
ཁྱི་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།དང་པོ་ནས་ར། བུ་མོ་གཅིག་ཁོང་ཚོ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།ག་ལེ་ག་ལེ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོང་ཚོ་ནང་ལ་ཅོ་ཅོ་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ཆུ་ཚོད་ཉར་རེད་(ད་)(ར)།
ཁྱི་དེ་ར་ཆུ་ཚོད་ཉར་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་ཨ་ཕ་ར། ཁོ་རང་ཨ་ཕ་དེ་ར།
དང་པོ་ཡོང་རེད་(ད)་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་སྐྱེལ་ནས། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་གུང་གསིང་རེད་ཡ།
སྔན་མ་གུང་གསིང་རེད་(ད)།དང་པོ་ནས་ར་པུ་གུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ག་འགྲོ་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
གཅིག་ར། འགྲོ་རེད་རེད་(ད)།ཡོང་རེད་(ད)།ན་རོགས་གྱིས་ལབ་རེད་(ད)་སྔན་མ་གཅིག་ལ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། རྐང་པ་གཅིག་ཡོད་(ད)།
རྐང་པ་ཛོར་པོ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།baby རྐང་པ་གཅིག ལྡབ་ལྡབ་ལྡབ་ལྡབ་བྱས་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་ཚོ་ཡོང་ར། baby གཞན་དག་གདོན་འདྲེ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།
ཨི་ནས་ར། འདམ་པ་དེ་སྒང་ལ།
ནག་ཁུངས་ནང་ལོགས་ལ་ར་ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་མར་ཉལ་ནས་ར་ཨ་ཕ་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽གཅིག་ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་འདི་ལ་ཉལ་བསྡད་རེད་ར།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གདོན་འདྲེ་གཅིག་གིས་མཐོང་ནས།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྫོགས་རེད། མ་རེད་(ད)།ད་དུང་མང་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཨི་ནས་ར། baby ཆུང་ཆུང་ཁོང་ཚོ་ར་སློབ་གྲྭ་འགྲོ་རེད་ར། ཨི་ནས་ར། ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་གིས་ར།
དང་པོ་ནས་ར། དཀར་པོ་རིང་པོ་གཅིག
ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།དཀར་པོ་ར། དཀར་པོ་གཅིག་ར།
གནམ་ལ་བསྡད་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།ཤིང་ནགས་སྒང་ལ་ཉལ་བསྡད་རེད་(ད)།ཉི་མ་ཤར་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་རང་coffee གཅིག་དགོས་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ང་འདི་འདྲས།
ཆགས་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ།
ལུས་བརྩལ་རྩེ་བྱས་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོ་རང་ཆེན་པོ་ཆགས་རེད་(ད་)(ར་)བུ་དེ། ཁོ་གཉིས་གཉིས་འདི་ཆེན་པོ་ཅོ་ཅོ་དེ་གི་རེད་ར། འདི་ཆེན་པོ་འདི།
སྐྲ་རིང་པོ་དེ་རེད་འདུག ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མི་འདི་སྲུ་མོ་དབྱངས་འཛོམས་མ་རེད་(ད)།སྲུ་མོ་དབྱངས་འཛོམས་འདི།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
ར། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། དང་པོ་ནས་ར། ཁོང་གཉིས་ཨ་ཕ་ལ་འཐམ་ར་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་འགྲོ་ཡ་ཡིན་bye bye ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་ཁོང་ཚོ་གཉིས་ར།
ར། ཞི་མི་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད། ཞི་མི་འདི་ལ་ཡོང་རེད་(ད)།ཁྱི་གཅིག་བྱས་མ་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། དེབ་གཅིག་ར།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། ཨི་ནས་ར།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། ཞི་མི་གཅིག་རག་རེད་ར།
ཞི་མི་འདི་ནང་ལ་འཛུལ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།ཁ་བཙུམ་བཙུམ་འདིའི་ནང་འཛུལ་བསྡད་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།དེ་ནས་ར་ཞི་མི་མཐོང་རེད་(ད)།
འདི་ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་ར། ཕལ་བརྩལ་རེད་(ད)།ཁོང་གཉིས་གཅིག་སླེབས་རེད་(ད)།
ལབ་རེད་(ད)།ཨ་ཕ་ང་ལྟ་ད་༼ང་རེའི་༽ball འདི་ལྟ་ད། ཁེར་ཉན་མང་པོ་ཞེ་པོ་འདུག་ད་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར། ཁོང་གཉིས་གཉིས་གིས་ར་དཔེ་མང་པོ་ལྟ་རེད་(ད)་༼ཨ་ནས༽། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
ཁྱི་གཅིག་ར།
འདི་ཁྱི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
ཁྱི་ར། འདི་ཁྱི་འདུག་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་ར་ཞེད་རེད་(ད་)(ར)། ཁོ་རྔུལ་ནག་མང་པོ་དོན་རེད་(ད)།
རྒྱུག་ཤར་གློད་ནས་ར། ཁོ་རང་འདི་ནང་བླུགས་ར། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་ཚ་བ་ཚིག་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོ་རང་ཆུ་འཐུང་ཡ་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་ཁོ་རང་།
ཁོ་རང་དཔེ་མང་པོ་འཛུལ་རེད་(ད)་འདི་ནང་ལ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་རང་དཔེ་མང་པོ་ཆུ་འཐུང་ཡ་རག་ཡོད་མ་རེད་(ད)།
བུ་མོ་ཁོང་གཉིས་ཆུ་བཀྲམ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར་དང་པོ་རེད་ར།
ད་དུང་གཅིག་བཤད་དགོས། ངས་ད་དུང་གཅིག་བཤད་དགོས་(ལོ)།
འདི་ནང་ལ་ད་དུང་གཅིག
རྔན་པ་སྟོན་ཙང་ར་སྟོངས་པ་ཆགས་རེད། ད་དུང་ནས་ཁྱི་གཅིག
དང་པོ་ནས་ཁྱི་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
བུ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།བུ་གཅིག་ཁོ་རང་།
དཔེ་མང་པོ་དོན་ད་ར། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཨ་ཕ་ར།
ཁོ་རང་ཆུ་ཚོད་ཉར་རེད་(ད)།ཁོ་རང་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་འགྲོ་ཡ་རེད་(ད)་(ལོ)། ཨ་ཕ་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
ཨ་ཕ་ང་ནང་ལ་སླེབས་ཡོད་མགྱོགས་པོ་ཤོག་ད་ལབ་རེད་(ད)།
ཁོ་རང་དཔེ་ཁུག་ར། སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་འདུག་ག ཁོ་རང་དཔེ་ཁུག་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་མི་འདུག་ག འདི་ཤོག་ད། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ར།
ད་དུང་ར། གཅིག་སྒོ་བརྒྱབ་རེད་(ད)།༼ཨ་ནས༽།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽གཅིག་སྒོ་བརྒྱབ་འདུག དེ་ཁོ་རང་ནང་ལ་ཡོང་ནས། ཁོ་རང་ལ་ཨ་ཕ།
དང་པོ་དེ་ར། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཚང་མ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽རྫོགས་རེད་(ད)།